Хто збудував Львів?
Тут не було ні одного містобудівельника.
Тут були архітектори: запрошені і місцеві.
Але ніхто з них не був містобудівельник.
Містобудівельник — це людина, яка під лінійку малює.
Як в Одесі, як  у Санкт-Петербурзі.
Містобудівельники —
ті, що малюють загальний вид.
Ніхто у Львові цього не робив.
Чого Львів такий гарний?
Бо сусід перед сусідом хизувався!
Жінка казала: «Я хочу вигляд на 4 вікна.
Ти з Італії привези. Ти що — грошей не маєш?»
«А дивись — вона зробила...»
І оця конкуренція збудувала геніальне місто.
Наше місто відрізняється від інших
саме такою приватною ініціативою.
Це одна з львівських утопій.
Але вона ще протрималась.
Бачите, 27 років Музею ідей і він якось протримався.
І в чому утопія полягає — це самостворений,
самодостатній культурологічний проєкт.
Тобто ми самі заробляємо на те,
що вкладаємо в культурологічні проєкти.
Так, ресторан працює на наші проєкти.
І гута скла працює на наші проєкти.
Це ті бізнес-часточки, які нас годують.
Творчість не виховується ні у ВНЗ, ні вдома.
Вона або стає твоєю конституційною
нормою і ти інакше не можеш...
Щодня щось придумуєш.
Тут шумно.
Філіал пекла.
Майстерня. Художня майстерня по склу.
Це пан Ігор і пан Олександр.
Мої друзі і наші майстри.
Оскільки на гуті
ніхто ніколи сам не працює —
це завжди колективна праця.
Бо тут є кілька допоміжних операцій.
Один — думає, другий — готує, третій — видуває.
Скло — це моя професія.
Перша освіта — архітектор,
а друга — художник, тому
це годує мене і мою сім'ю вже багато років.
Я виріс на скульптурно-керамічній фабриці.
Я дуже багато там проєктував як архітектор,
потім працював у кераміці.
А на це чудо якесь я дивився з заздрістю завжди.
Вони там завжди творили.
Мені дуже подобалось, що це одразу реалізовується.
Набрав – получилось.
Якщо геніальне – то ти молодець.
І це італійці дуже вправно називають
«la prima» – з першого разу.
Я заздрив їм.
Дуже довго їм заздрив, а потім почав робити.
Гута — це горно, піч, пічка.
Якщо Ви зауважили в Галичині дуже багато сіл,
які називаються «гута»
Там були старі залізні,
на яких виплавляли залізо або скло.
Найскладніше те, що цю піч не можна загасити.
І якщо ти хочеш поїхати кудись:
відпочити, в якесь відрядження.
Піч горить день і ніч.
За 27 років ми зробили добрих три десятки проєктів
загальноміських, державних.
Понад 800 мистецьких виставок.
Оці два зали у нас експозиційні.
Тут час від часу відбуваються
різні перформенси, театральні вистави.
Там ще є зал для глядачів.
Ідея — це щось таке...
Я зробив виставку таку, дивну:
люди ходили плечима знизували.
Стояла понад сотня трилітрових слоїків,
які були закриті кришками.
Більше нічого не було.
Вони були порожні.
І коли питали: «Що це?»,
ми говорили — «Там ідеї».
Я не знаю староарамеської мови,
але я свято переконаний, що Письмо,
Святе Письмо, коли його перекладали
то перекрутили головну фразу.
Може спочатку була ідея, а не слово?
Це моя думка.
У це я вірю.
І той, кому такі сентенції близькі,
то вони приходять і тут себе знаходять, як вдома.
Виставляють ідеї. Приносять свої ідеї.
«О, треба реалізувати!»
Я кажу: «Ідея хороша — то беріть і реалізуйте»
Зараз Сашко набрав другий шар.
Хоч, дивіться, який він і кривий, але всередині є холодна,
поки що холодна, рівностінна баночка.
Катальником Сашко заспокоює це скло
і врівноважує довкола цієї бульбашки.
Зараз пінцами — такими щипцями, він зарізає.
І зараз це називається «зарізна банка»
і буде третій раз набиратися скло на зарізну банку.
З нашими комплексами люди
хочуть бути на когось подібні:
їсти суші, піцу і т.д.
Це добре, це позитивно.
Але, по правді кажучи, я ніколи не зустрічав
ні в Парижі, ні в інших серйозних містах
вареничної чи щось подібне.
Вона там мають свою кухню
і для того люди приїжджають до них в гості.
До Львова ж приїжджати на суші
навіть для японців здавалося б дивним.
І ми вирішили зробити такий контраверс.
Повернутися до нашої традиції,
яка має свої великі особливості.
Має свої позитиви.
І люди відгукнулися.
Людям це подобається.
Особливо іноземці приїжджають,
знають точно, що це галицька кухня.
Оскільки в нас все пов'язано з цим приміщенням,
яке містить відбиток часу.
Це монастирські підвали.
Тому ми намагаємось чемно поводитись.
І заклад називається «Трапезна ідей»
Ми підтримуємо традицію,
наскільки нам дозволяють етичні норми,
ми підтримуємо традицію
спільної трапези, монастирської трапези.
Тобто з одного боку це пошана традицій,
а з іншого – популяризація...
нашого обличчя. Суші – не наше.
Я радів як дитина нещодавно,
коли побачив чергову голівудську комедію.
І там на полиці в сантабарбарі стоять мої клоуни.
Є такий розділ гутної традиції –
венеційські клоуни.
Такі великі.
І от ми з Ігорем, Сашою і ще двома працівниками
12 років робили в Лос-Анджелес такі поставки.
До нас приїжджав великий морський контейнер.
Ми мабуть два десятки таких контейнерів
відправили в Америку тих клоунів.
Тож зараз наші клоуни є по цілому світу.
У цьому місці скло стає розжареним
і зараз Ігор буде, піддуваючи,
ліквідовувати товщину у цьому місці.
Товщина зникатиме.
Можна було б і так зупинитись.
Вона мені і такою подобається.
І остаточно кронку, яка зараз, зрозуміло, є гострою,
край нагрівається і стає рукотворним, м'яким.
Робиться в гарячий спосіб, наживо.
Дірки можуть бути в різних місцях.
І це видно, що це ручна робота.
Це ми самі розписували.
Моя сестра очолила групу студентів.
Ми, з цього залу, де все було залито болотом по вінця, —
звідти текло болото, в вікна текло,
витікало аж туди, ми вивезли звідси
тільки чотири чи п'яти машин болота.
А потім вирішили осушити
і зробити таке піднебесся в підземеллі.
Сьогодні всі кажуть, що це XVII століття, — і я їм вірю.
Але...
До речі, над входом, там є образ «Благовіщення»
Я періодично слухаю екскурсії,
і дуже задоволений з того, що вони роблять.
Мало того – вони називають автора, це кінець 17 століття.
А це абсолютно українська Богоматір стоїть з Гавриїлом.
Легендами обростає весь Львів.
На вулиці нашій «кінолевівській» [вул. Архівна]
всі розказують, що Філліні приїжджав на Кінолев.
Я кажу: «Та він тут. Ми з ним спагетті готували».
Він був, правда, спіритично присутній.
Але для журналістів – це таке.
Є продукування, тиражування,
а є такий м'який дотик.
Такий кусочок душі на вікні там, на столі.
що все залежить від освіченості і від культури.
А те, що українці мають смак, —
це можна подивитися на наше мистецтво.
Без всяких академій, без нічого
наш народ творив такі речі, від яких завмирають.
Мистецтвознавці дивляться і завмирають.